en el último vídeo les mostré la
definición de la eficiencia eta que es
el trabajo que hacemos entre el calor
que aplicamos y mostramos que para una
máquina que podríamos reescribir esto
como 1 - q 2 o entre 1 o esencialmente 1
menos
esencialmente es uno menos el calor que
sacamos entre el calor que pusimos ok
ahora aplicamos esta fórmula a un ciclo
de carne y dijimos bueno para un una
máquina de carenote podríamos escribir
la eficiencia de esta forma así que
déjenme escribir esto de aquí la
eficiencia para una máquina de carne es
uno menos de 2 / t 1 para obtener este
resultado usamos el hecho de que estamos
trabajando con un ciclo de carnota ok
nos movemos a lo largo de las isotermas
y a veces este entre el en procesos a
diabéticos en fin déjenme ser muy claro
esta deficiencia que sólo puede
obtenerse a través de una máquina de
carne las otras definiciones de
eficiencia ok esta eficiencia es igual
al trabajo entre el calor déjenme
ponerle el calor que aplicamos o cuando
definimos esto la edad como como el
cambio el que déjenme ponerlo así
el calor neto que es 1 - q 2 sobre 11
esto aplica para cualquier máquina de
calor o que incluso las máquinas de
calor de carnot perdón una máquina no sé
por ejemplo esta máquina que hicimos es
una máquina de carnota y definitivamente
es una máquina que está operando con
calor y está tomando calor y luego lo
libera en fin este ciclo solo muestra
qué es lo que está ocurriendo con esta
máquina ok esta máquina es la cosa
física el ciclo sólo describe qué es lo
que está pasando con él así que con esto
dicho lo que quiero decir es está esta
fórmula sólo es para ciclos o para
máquinas de carnota ahora al final de
este vídeo no creo terminar pero quiero
probarles al menos en el próximo que que
si operamos una máquina de calor que
está trabajando con 22 fuentes de
temperatura porque digamos que esta es
la temperatura ph para acá
vamos a ponerle tercer de caliente ok y
transfiere cierto calor q1 ok a cierto
a la máquina y después libera un calor
q2 y está realizando cierto trabajo
entonces el q2 lo libera a un depósito
frío digamos y aquí es donde el liberar
calor y lo que les voy a mostrar en el
próximo vídeo espero es que la máquina
más eficiente es la máquina teórica de
carne de que no hay otra máquina que
pueda ser más eficiente que ésta así que
si ésta es una máquina de carne es la
más eficiente ok es la más eficiente o
ésta es la ideal donde nada se pierde ok
vamos a entrar en eso con más detalle no
hay máquina que pueda ser más eficiente
que la de carnota que la máquina de
carne así que para llegar a ello voy a
probarles primero un poquito o vamos a
hablar sobre las herramientas que de las
que dispone hasta este tipo de máquinas
así que una de las cosas que vamos a ver
es déjenme dibujar de nuevo estos
diagramas de presión volumen o cups
ese es este spa y este es de entonces en
el ciclo de carnet que hemos hecho hasta
ahora siempre nos hemos movido a lo
largo de una dirección verdad teníamos
nos movíamos siempre a lo largo de éste
isoterma de más o menos de esta forma ok
después teníamos una expansión a
diabética
y ahí teníamos nuestra expansión a
diabética en esta dirección y después
teníamos una contracción hizo térmica
verdad nos movíamos algo de esta forma
ok y luego teníamos una contracción a
diabética para llegar a esto y nos
regresamos al punto inicial todo este
tiempo en una dirección en el sentido de
las agujas del reloj cuando cuando
fuimos en ese sentido aquí introducimos
un calor q no para para mantener nuestra
temperatura constante y después lo
libera vamos con q 2 ok
así que si fuera dibujar esto de alguna
otra forma bueno ya lo hice un poco
diferente pero bueno déjenme dibujar
esto digamos que esta es mi máquina ok a
lo mejor muy abstracto verdad ok y acá
arriba vamos a tener mi depósito de
calor de 1 ok que está transfiriendo un
calor q 1 a mi máquina de carnota
ok mi máquina entonces realiza cierto
trabajo y después transfiere cierto
calor a mi depósito con temperatura t2
transfiere q2 esta es otra forma de
ejemplificar lo que hicimos en este
ciclo de carnota y de hecho hemos aquí
estamos dibujando incluso la máquina no
ahora una de las herramientas que quiero
mostrarles es que esta es una reacción
reversible o de que podemos tomar esto e
ir en el sentido contrario y esto es
depende de la cidh de la suposición de
que cuando dibujamos esto en realidad
estamos hablando de un proceso cuasi
estático aunque hay un proceso cuasi
estático y casi estático significa que
realmente es muy lento que siempre
puedes decir que estamos muy cerca del
equilibrio para que nuestra nuestro
macro estado esté siempre definido y eso
era toda la justificación de trabajar
con canillitas o con granitos de esta
forma verdad moviendo las los granitos y
yéndonos de aves sin sin saltar sino que
fuera un proceso continuo ok eso era lo
que hacía un proceso cuasi estático para
nosotros y cuando hacíamos esto estos
vídeos decíamos bueno los procesos cuasi
estáticos la mayor parte de ellos son
reversibles y ok la mayor parte de todos
ellos son reversibles ahora por
definición nuestro ciclo de carl no
teórico
no solo es cuasi estático sino también
en reversible que significa que en
cualquier punto o en cualquier momento
podríamos ir regresando los granitos y
entonces podríamos ir agregando los
granitos y en vez de ir en la dirección
hacia la derecha podríamos regresar
hacia la izquierda ok
podríamos regresar esto ahora que tiene
que ser ideal para de este sistema para
que esto sea cierto bueno significa que
nuestro pistón a lo largo de él que se
va moviendo ejerciendo cierta presión y
disminuyendo el volumen no podemos
perder calor y ese calor se puede perder
a través de la fricción entonces tenemos
que suponer que que a la hora de irse
hacia abajo y hacia arriba no estamos
perdiendo calor a través de la fricción
así que este para que este ciclo de
carnal sea reversible es sin fricción
ok sin fricción así que la máquina de
carnota
y no puede tener fricción que realmente
es completamente imposible que no haya
fricción pero bueno hablaremos de un
poquito un poco más de esto en un futuro
entonces si tenemos una máquina que no
tiene fricción cuasi estática y
reversible que significa o que implica
implica que podríamos ir de este punto a
ok y en vez de irnos debe y luego 6 de
epo dyn podemos irnos en sentido
contrario podemos irnos primero haciendo
una una expansión digamos una expansión
pero nos vamos de forma diabética
déjenme dibujarlo de nuevo aunque vamos
a hacer esta reacción reversible vamos a
hacerlo en el sentido contrario ok ok
entonces dado que el sistema no tiene
fricción y no vamos a perder energía ok
entonces podemos empezar en el punto a
ok y hacer una expansión a diabética de
tal forma que lleguemos
a este estado que es de ok y luego
podemos expandir y so térmicamente
entonces vamos en esta dirección y luego
expandimos hizo térmicamente hasta y con
como estamos expandiéndolo de esta forma
y dibujarlo así a lo largo de éste
isoterma lo que estamos haciendo una
expansión hizo térmica en este caso
estamos realizando un trabajo verdad un
trabajo hizo térmico entonces a una
temperatura que podemos decir no sé que
es fría una temperatura de 2 ok en este
caso sí estoy expandiendo y estoy
permaneciendo en temperatura t2 entonces
el calor está entrando el calor está
entrando así que el área debajo de esta
curva es el es el calor agregado ok a lo
mejor ya notarás que estos son algo un
poco raro pero bueno este es el calor q2
que el depósito realiza con temperatura
t 2 luego con traemos de forma diabética
con traemos de forma diabética
ok y luego de forma hizo térmica con
traemos hasta llegar al punto inicial ok
ahora cuando contraemos hizo
térmicamente qué es lo que ocurrió el
trabajo está realizado para mí
ok hacia el sistema así que el área
debajo de esa curva es negativa ok
aquí vamos a liberar calor vamos a
liberar calor pero estamos liberando lo
algo con temperatura alta digamos aquí t
1 ok es la misma cosa que ocurrió antes
pero en el centro en una dirección
contraria
ok cierto trabajo en vez de ser aplicado
perdón en vez de realizar el sistema un
trabajo nosotros estamos aplicando un
trabajo porque el área dentro del es
negativa ok
por ejemplo esto es todo esto es
positivo todo esto que estamos pintando
de azul luego lo que va a ser negativo
es esto morado así que si queremos ver
más o menos cuál es el área dentro del
área o más bien la cantidad que sería el
área dentro del ciclo sería negativa yo
sé que suena raro pero matemáticamente
tiene sentido
entonces sí sí sí pensamos en el ciclo
de carnota o en la máquina de carnota en
sentido contrario es un refrigerador
esencialmente la otra sería como un
motor ok
estamos usando calor para tomar ventaja
de ese calor ok o de esa diferencia
entre temperaturas que aquí es caliente
ya lo mejor acá es frío y ahora al
revertir una máquina de carenote
podríamos pensarlo como un refrigerador
que hace exactamente lo contrario que es
lo que dibuje acá abajo lo que dice es
que empieza con un cuerpo frío aunque un
cuerpo frío vamos a ponerle dedos que es
de frío y que le mete cierta pequeña
cantidad de calor de este cuerpo ok pero
cierto trabajo en vez de salir debe
inyectarse al trabajar al sistema la
máquina ok así que eso mete más calor ok
en esta máquina y eso hace que le dé más
temperatura al cuerpo caliente
le da un cierto q1 al cuerpo con
temperatura de 1 ok
así que podríamos
que si estuviéramos en una máquina
digamos este es un refrigerador que
estamos en una dirección revertida ok no
hay nada malo con esto no estamos
contradiciendo la segunda ley de la
termodinámica porque qué es lo que está
ocurriendo en realidad nosotros estamos
inyectando cierto trabajo al cis a la
máquina ok ya hablamos un poquito de
esto verdad en los vídeos de entropía
como esto es un refrigerador estamos
metiendo trabajo a la máquina para que
esto compense la segunda ley de la
termodinámica es que en un refrigerador
como los de casa es un compresor quien
hace ese trabajo ok está agregando más
entropía al sistema ok entonces esto no
nos desafía la segunda ley de la
termodinámica ahora quiero hacer otro
punto acerca de las máquinas de carnets
ok sólo un poquito más déjenme tomar
la máquina revertida o el refrigerador
si tomamos esto esto simplemente es más
que no es más que matemáticas entonces
si tomamos esto si tomamos estamos
tomando q 2 agregándole también cierto
trabajo y produce q 1 en cierta escala
que es bastante arbitraria por ejemplo
si tomamos x veces q 2 ok si tomamos x
veces q 2 ok ahí tenemos x leds escudos
y le metemos x veces w entonces va a
salir x q uno porque esto tiene sentido
simplemente son números arbitrarios por
ejemplo si tuviéramos dos máquinas de
carnota en paralelo simplemente podremos
ver como que tenemos dos de estas
máquinas trabajando juntas entonces
tendríamos dos dos de cada una de las
unidades si tuviéramos tres máquinas de
kart no tendremos una máquina colectiva
trabajando al triple ok ahora con esto
dicho ya tenemos todo todo el preámbulo
para demostrar que la máquina de carnota
la más eficiente que podríamos producir
y dado que la máquina de carne la
eficiencia de carnota es esta y vamos a
demostrar que es la más eficiente
entonces esto se vuelve una cota
superior para la eficiencia de cualquier
máquina que cualquier persona en el
mundo podría ser algún día y eso será el
punto del próximo vídeo